trois à quatre ans de prison pour 15 des
vols y gagnent dans la responsabilité
est établie voilà ce que le procureur du
roi a requis ce soir les juges
apprécieront pour huit autres suporters
anglais dont la responsabilité n'a pas
été établi de manière formelle deux
autres devraient être acquittés faute de
preuves
le procureur du roi n'a pas ménagé ses
coups de patte aux supporters anglais
qu'il a accusés d'être des spécialistes
du double langage déguisé en premier
communiant par commodité du côté des
inculpés pas de réaction
l'urgence ce soir était de rentrer à
liverpool
les élus et les responsables de la
municipalité de bruxelles qui est
propriétaire du stade du heysel ont été
mis hors de cause par le procureur de
même plus les responsables de l'uefa
l'union européenne de football amateur
en revanche le procureur a mis au pilori
les leaders de l'union belge de football
pour avoir privilégié le profit au
détriment de la sécurité
de même pour les forces de l'ordre des
organisations bureaucratisme et manque
d'initiative se sont donc l'union belge
de football et l'état belge qui auront à
indemniser les victimes de la soirée
sanglante du 29 mai 1985 au stade du
heysel